three of Nikes best marathon runners
will try to make history this weekend on
a racetrack near Milan Italy they want
to be the first to run a marathon in two
hours or less to do that they will need
to break the world record marathon time
by nearly three minutes well Dana
Jacobson is here with the race to reach
a milestone of human endurance
fascinated by the story Dana good
morning good morning yeah two hours two
minutes and 57 seconds
that's the fastest any human has ever
run a 26.2 mile marathon it is so close
to the two-hour mark and yet so far Nike
is one of two shoe companies vying to
break through that barrier neither would
have gotten this close without a lot of
help from science my gore-tex shoes on
today the morning after a late spring
snowstorm in Boulder Colorado we do get
snow and ice sometimes roger cram and
Wouter Hulk Dahmer go for their daily
run it's a beautiful day though but for
this pair running is more than just a
hobby so what we're doing is measuring
Peters rate of oxygen consumption their
scientists at the University of Colorado
on your mark go studying ways to make
runners faster all right exactly unfazed
and they're trying to solve a very
specific challenge bring the
world-record marathon time below two
hours 48 seconds the world record is
just a hair under two hours and three
minutes so we need to save three minutes
in order to get under two hours that's
it
tighten it up in a recently published
study they found a few surprisingly
simple changes in tactics and equipment
could do the trick first if an elite
runner wants to break the record he has
to choose a race with the right course
one which also conforms to the rules of
the sport's governing body if you had a
course that had the maximum downhill
dropping about 130 feet that saves about
30 seconds he also needs to outwit the
wind cram and Huck Dahmer think they've
found the answer
drafting if we could get for runners to
cooperate and take turns at the front
breaking the wind that also could save
about three minutes according to our
calculations time to change places right
behind him Peter
this idea of drafting in running yes
which obviously can help but we don't
see it why not
running is usually everybody's on their
own and we say like alright guys if you
can just work together here and you
probably need some incentive for runners
to make that happen
finally it all comes down to the shoe if
we can make a shoe lighter by a hundred
grams we save 1% in energy and how much
time is that usually at the top level
marathoners saving 1% is one minute but
the shoes weight isn't the only factor
the amount of cushioning in the sole
determines how much energy or spring the
runner gets back with each stride two of
the biggest names in the sport Adidas
and Nike have built brand new shoes
specifically to break the two hour
marathon milestone the two companies are
taking somewhat different approaches the
new Nike shoe is light but it's it's not
the lightest shoe but it has the best
cushioning and energy return the adidas
shoe they've seemed to have kept the
same amount of energy returned as they
had in the older model but made it a
hundred grams lighter here on try the
new ones the bolder team tested Nikes
entry in the two-hour milestone race
they're really light I mean I this is
ridiculous its findings even gave the
shoe its name it's gonna try the vapor
fly 4% oh my I can feel the spring right
away
this shoe saves about 4% of energy and
so if a person was say running a 10
minute mile that's about 24 seconds per
mile that's me at the elite level if we
had someone who could run a marathon in
the phenomenal time of two hours and
four minutes right we think this shoe
can take off enough time to get them
under under - what's the big deal about
a sub-2 marathon this is a bit like a
moonshot what appeals to me is that
other people were saying no it's
impossible and I'd like to prove them
wrong at this weekend's world-record
attempt in Italy Nikes utilizing two of
the factors that crams groups studied
the new shoe and that drafting formation
and it's important to point out that all
three of Nikes Pro marathoners making
this attempt already have
personal best times that are within
minutes of the world record awesome yeah
awesome
I need those energy returned you give me
whatever it is you run you would feel at
the moment that you put that shoe on
that's good for Nora to know thank you